have you ever been over there India yeah
no no no I did a gig over there man it
was amazing come on a gig yeah you did a
gig in India yeah it was amazing what
and I'll tell you the people they're
[ __ ] hilarious they're ball Breakers
when I I called up this podcast and they
were just talking to me going like hey
you gonna talk about this and I was like
ah you know I don't know they're going
to talk about that they just kept
leading me on these so you can talk
about religion or something and I was
like you know I don't I go wait are you
guys talking about this stuff and then
they started laughing they were trying
to get me in trouble what city was this
uh Mumbai which used to be Bombay of
course no kidding all right I'm not
trying to you know okay I get it you
have a globe no no no
Mumbai Mumbai it's the city that was
attacked so viciously in 2008. you
remember the attack Protestants
the Amish I believe was yeah I love a
water yeah no no who was it was uh it
was Pakistan
is it Pakistan it was a Muslim attack on
Hindu India I mean and boy did they I
mean they went through that City that
that hotel that they attacked I think
they made a movie about it the hotel
Mumbai or something yeah well when I was
there they had yeah they had like people
with like machine guns oh and stuff out
front but it was like uh
they were uh they had beautiful people
man never said they all jammed in
together and you think that they'd be
like New York right but they weren't
they you know I'm not gonna lie to you
there was people walking around t-shirts
that said real men don't rape and I was
like uh what's what's up with that
you're like that's really not here
that's a little bit north of here it's
like all right every country's got you
know their old school Times Square you
know that city is one of the
the greatest income inequality examples
in the world because there's
billionaires there's a house there that
is like I don't know something like I
don't know 50 stories high or something
and the guy owns the whole thing right
and then there are the slum dogs I mean
there are people who literally live in
that sewage I mean what their immune
systems must be like over there just
incredible yeah no it was it was a uh I
don't think they need the vaccine no I
Really they are the vaccines I think
they they're good yeah no but it was uh
it was quite a
I would go back in a second that's how
much I enjoyed it I would go back in a
second it's just I got two kids now and
I I it's just such a long flight to try
to get back there but I would go back
there
in a second and the perspective it gives
you you know how cool they are how funny
they are and then all the stuff that
they're dealing with and like just all
just going over to Asia was amazing to
travel over there because they literally
have everything that we have but just
different people doing it right down
they have their own rock stars their own
airplanes and stuff and you stay here
and you think oh everybody is into what
we're doing and they're over there and
they don't give a [ __ ] and their own
movie yeah it's amazing Bollywood I mean
it's a whole entire movie industry up
there that is different than ours so how
does it say though but you like watch it
and you're kind of like oh this is their
Bruce Willis I get this guy right no
it's it's because there are just so many
stories to tell uh but how did they know
you over there from podcast really from
podcast yeah podcast people like uh
they they like I have people Netflix I
have people Netflix your special is huge
on Netflix yeah fantastic by the way um
oh thank you and then there's uh other
there's people in countries they're not
supposed to be listened to her will
reach out and tell me that they listen
to I never say what countries because I
don't know what goes on the black van
pulls up I don't want to be a part of it
right but like it's it's a really like
uh
yeah no it's great like um I was in
Italy one time and some kid from like
Serbia or something came up to me
because you Bill Burr and he said it
with the accent I said yeah he goes he
goes hey Monday Morning podcast go [ __ ]
yourself
like you gotta be kidding me I go you
listen to that [ __ ] yeah I got a picture
with them and everything was awesome